stuffed lamb with spinach and pine nuts
stuffed meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive taste
amazing but more importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of rolls-royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing to an absolute tea for
the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamp
now we've got the color on those onions
we're going to throw in some pine nuts
and that helps to give a bit of a
texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting spinach in
and just lay the spinach over the pine
nuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
going to condense and disappear almost
instantly
there's so much more flavor and spinach
when you saute it as opposed to steaming
it or boiling it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumbled feta over the spinach
feta cheese adds a beautifully salty
sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings our stuffing together
now
open up
the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
sour
sumac is a wonderful lemony spice that
goes brilliantly with lamb and you can
get it in most big supermarkets and it
sort of cuts through that thick rich
sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon
if you're preparing this for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's gonna
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of
increase that beautiful tunnel
and then from there
over
there
and bring that
towards you
and then roll
like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now
to tie it first off
around the side
and don't worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle you can get butcher's
string from your local butcher or at
cookware shops
i got two ties
go to thai it just forces all that
stuffing out of the lamb when it's in
the oven
nice
now we'll just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing is coming out the
sides really important
look at that color beautiful it does
kick start the roasting process
gas off
into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tail the cucumber
peel it
cut the cucumber
into three
and just core
taking out all that it's just sort of
watery seedy and
it spoils the flavor slice the cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
gonna dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint
dressing a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested
carefully take off the string
and then just gently pull them back
straighted edge knife that's going to
cut through that crispy fat on the
outside instantly i tied it purposely so
i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing meat
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast slow-cooked fiery lamb
cooking is all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it cooks the more flavoursome it
becomes
marinating the lamb first
chilis we're gonna use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there
cooking
for up to three hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
a touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb olive
oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it sliced
secret slicing vegetables from braising
is not getting too thin you slice the
onions too thin they burn you've got
that horrible char taste on that slow
braised braising it's just a chef's term
that means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat incredibly moist
and beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil
lamb in hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chilies
cinnamon
in
mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're
getting the collar on the lamb which
washes off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up and get the
lamb
sat
on top of the vegetables
now just glaze the pan with red wine
this glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish
always delays
then bring to the boil and cook for
about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and incredibly tender grab it by
the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce nice
beautiful
just get some mint
don't chop it
just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow
and there you go a very spicy delicious
melting in the mouth
lamb shank amazing
sponge with fresh ginger
bacon is part chemistry
part imagination but you've got to rely
on the rules for great results the only
time you'll see me reaching for the
scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when i
say weigh out the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final gram
175
now 175 grams
of sugar
that's 350 grams in total cream
the butter and the
sugar to get a delicious light sponge
start carefully on slow speed
[Music]
only speed up as the butter and sugar
really start to cream together
keep that really nice and light you can
see how it's changed color so important
at the beginning
eggs in
give me a little whisk
adding one egg at a time stops the mix
from separating
second egg in
third one in
[Music]
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light airy texture
now i'm gonna flavor the sponge
a little teaspoon of vanilla extract
that perfumes the mix
one teaspoon of baking powder that gives
lightness 175 grams of flour
and we're going to sieve it a to get rid
of any lumps and b to keep it really
nice and fine
175.
we're not going to beat that out we're
just going to lightly fold that in now
what i'm looking for is a really nice
loose dough
that's looking a little bit too firm so
just a little splash of milk
a couple of tablespoons that relaxes the
mixture down
helps create that nice almost dropping
consistency
that's what i want
just starting to drop
take a non-stick loose bottom cake tin
grease it with butter then coat it with
flour to avoid the sponge sticking
just give that a little shake
make sure you get all the rim
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you've got no peaks on my
sponge
to make sure the sponge bakes nice and
evenly tap the tin a few times to knock
out any air pockets that might have
formed in the mixture
now into the oven
bake for 30 to 35 minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare the ginger
cream for the center 300ml of cream give
that a nice whisk
whisking the cream by hand gives you so
much more control and it's so easy to
over whipped cream i want that nice
light ginger cream in the center i don't
want it grainy nothing worse when cream
starts to separate
now let's get into that three-quarter
stage
little stiff peaks
stop that for two minutes fresh ginger
now get a really nice large slice of
ginger
smells incredible
it's so fragrant good green ginger is
like sort of peeling a potato just take
out all those little dark spots
now get your grater
you haven't gotten grater you can chop
the ginger really finely
i've gone almost like a puree of ginger
going through but the juice as well
take your knife
and just scrape all that
taste
incredible it's fragrant
it's not sweet it's got a really nice
taste
set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible
run a knife around the outside to ensure
the cake doesn't stick to the tin before
turning it out
now get your hands under push up
and out
while your cake cools i'm gonna do like
a really nice sweet chocolate coating
pour 300 mils of double cream into a
saucepan add two tablespoons of golden
syrup to make the top nice and glossy
then whisk
chop this up really thinly
so as it melts
quickly
50 grams of butter that's gonna give the
chocolate a really nice shine
ball your cream and
mix it
in
give that a really good stir
as the chocolate the butter melts it
thickens like how shiny that is
it's so nice to finish something sweet
on top
topping done time to build your sponge
cake
look at the halfway mark there
and just gently
slice
and really take your time all the way
through
lift
that's delicious
a nice big dollop in the middle don't be
stingy don't be tight with a cream
another dollop on top
spread that
very carefully lift the lid and just sit
that on top that's why i start off with
a little extra cream in there so i
squash it down the cream just pushes out
to the side
i'm not finished
pour the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge
be generous and make sure the cake is
coated thoroughly to give it a gorgeous
finish
get the bottom of the ladle and spread
whoa
one more
[Music]
wow
you've got to know when to say stop and
something looks that delicious
i just want to dive in there
wonderful baked cheesecake for me food
always has to be impressive but when it
comes to desserts
often you see spun sugar or wild
decorations remember simple
is always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now cream cheese leave it out the fridge
for five or ten minutes go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is the new york
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar spending the amount of time i
do in the states if there's one thing
they know how to do out there is the
most amazing impressive cheesecake rich
delicious but so simple
work the bowl
lift the bowl to your advantage
whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy now
get your eggs
add the eggs to the mixture bit by bit
doing it this way it's more efficient
hey you're incorporating a lot of air
b the mixture doesn't separate
lastly your egg
lovely
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
a cheesecake a day
keep the bingo wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk
stop something going lumpy
now i want to scent that cheesecake
i've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there i want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in
some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through
be careful to crush them
then grease a cake tin with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
the mixture hits the bottom of the cake
tin the raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture in the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
slightly souffled up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color i wanted
on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest
yet the most stylish cheesecakes
anywhere
beautiful
[Music]